[Music]
and so begins up to 24 hours of Defense
of the president but so confident or his
legal team that he will be acquitted
they're likely to finish much earlier
this Saturday session lasted just two
hours and was used as a preview ahead of
fuller arguments on Monday with tight
speeches to grab the attention of
senators they're asking you to remove
President Trump from the ballot in an
election that's occurring in
approximately nine months they're asking
you to tear up all of the ballots across
this country on your own initiative take
that decision away from the American
people
Donald Trump has long argued that his
controversial phone call to the
Ukrainian president szalinski was
perfect rather than his critics claim an
attempt to force the Ukrainians to
investigate his Democratic rival Joe
Biden and his attorneys demonstrated
that not everyone who was listening in
to the call was concerned mr. Trump had
overstepped the line Mr Morrison
repeatedly testified that he disagreed
with Lieutenant Colonel VIN moons
assessment that President Trump made
demands of President zalenski or that he
said anything improper at all
here's mr. Morrison in that transcript
does the president not ask Solinsky to
look into the Biden's mr. Chairman I can
only tell you what I was thinking at the
time that is not what I understood the
president's be doing do you believe in
your opinion that the present States
demanded the president Solinsky
undertake these investigations no sir
and you didn't hear the president make
it demand did you no sir Trump's
personal lawyer Jay Sekulow is also
involved in the defense his boss took to
Twitter to urge his followers to watch
mr. Trump whose national profile was
built on the ratings of his reality TV
show The Apprentice complained that his
impeachment defense was started on a
Saturday when hardly anyone is watching
television and in truth much of the
drama has already gone out of these
proceedings as it appears ever more
likely that Republicans have the votes
to prevent witnesses
from testifying despite all the evidence
which Democrats have gathered to make
their case they know that real live
testimony is more likely to shift
entrenched opinions if they were really
interested in the American people
knowing all the facts they wouldn't be
fighting to make sure that this is the
first trial in history without witnesses
objection so ordered the Senate is
adjourned they'll be back on Monday but
it's possible this trial could be over
by the end of next week in woods Sky
News Washington